hi i'm ryan right and I'm John Connor
welcome reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see blast and
so let's hang out Lions consensus there
are a lot of reasons to see the last
stand there are a lot of reasons to see
the last stand really well you liked it
I just [ __ ] with eg Oh John Connors
consensus I think there are a lot of
reasons to see the last step there are a
lot of reasons to see the last step
reason to see number one Arnold [ __ ]
Schwarzenegger they [ __ ] with the
wrong guy Arnel did a good job like when
you know like you an arnold gets hurt in
this movie you you feel the hurt he
sells you on the character it surprised
me it is sort of freaked me out i was
buying the character you know it's it's
arnold doing his arnold thing but at the
same time I don't feel like this was
written for Arnold it was just like I'll
find something for on the B and I felt
like they had a story and a character
then they got Arnold to be in it I just
watching this I felt like they wrote the
character and he played the character
he's great at parroting himself reason
to see number two the action I like the
whole big-city crime versus small town
crime yeah it's kind of like two movies
rolled into one this one could have been
a great 3d movie like with Arnold
walking with shotgun apparently i got an
inverted more that's not fun for Holden
good source ogre shotgun just that like
last 30 minutes was so [ __ ] cool you
know sometimes it's badass sometimes
it's intriguing sometimes it's funny you
know sometimes over the top like it's
got a whole blend of stuff and it's it's
awesome reason to see number three the
directing oh yeah I thought they nailed
this one with flying colors man I mean
kim jiwan's direction is great and it
you know
it's over the top but it follows the
rules of its universe really well so it
doesn't seem too over-the-top were
pushed in any one direction it's like
everything is justified it's just a
really good time even when it's taking
its time seriously even the cheesy bad
scenes were fun I honestly thought
there'd be more cheesiness in this film
but it doesn't take away from the fun of
the movie no and nothing and even when
it is cheesy it's not bad cheating it's
just enough seriousness to make you care
about the characters I didn't feel like
it was just let's put some explosions
and stuff and people will like it it
doesn't matter you know let's just have
people so they can die you know that
this is the sort of thing we've listened
for a while with action movies the
expendables wishes it could be this film
no it's not too much of anything it's
just enough to make it thrilling and
exciting and then it's also fun but not
too much long where you forget about the
characters like it does slow down to
take time for characters and it sets up
its world and it does a good job of that
I feel like people who are like not
liking this movie like based off a lot
of the opinions I'm hearing it sounds
like they went into this movie prepared
not to like it this type of movie gets a
write-off anyway reason to see number
for cinematography cinematography is
really bad asthma the film did look good
just crazy angles and moving shots
reason to see number five it's fun and
funny you know I had a great time I dug
the [ __ ] out of it it has--it's cheese
and stuff and as far as this type of
movie goes they got it right I thought
you know it's it's simple but it's not
stupid when I first heard that it was
close to two hours i was a little turned
off by that after watching this i was so
invested in the material i wasn't like
pulled in like a great drama I was so
wrapped by it already yeah by the time
it was over I felt like I just watched
an 80-minute movie yeah I feel myself
laughing a lot during this movie as well
even the violence sometimes makes you
laugh reason to see number six the
writing you know everybody was a
character people weren't just talking
about the plot you know they took some
time to make it fun and amusing
like I get the sense that these
characters existed even without this
story yeah man I was along with the
journey the whole time yeah the blood
moves along very well it seems like
somebody actually paid attention when
they were writing this movie plain and
simple it's just smart it's a smart
action film at the very least there's a
story and it's about the characters
everything has a personality movies like
this needs some substance and this movie
gives you that unlike inks respond
reason to see number 7 the supporting
cast you could just ride this movie off
Arnold and you know half as it but it
seemed like everybody was involved and
really cared it's Arnold with an
insomnia mo you know any time someone
gets shot you feel that at first when I
saw a forest whitaker in this movie I
was like what the hell is this Academy
award-winning actor doing in this kind
of a movie but he seemed to be very
aware the type of film he was in and he
actually did a very good job you solid
you know who else I liked I liked the
two villains I thought both films were
fun to watch especially the one who is
fighting against Arnold in the town Minh
first Oh Peter Stormare he's always
popping up as slimy bad guys yeah no
he's he's great he's a lot of fun to
watch yeah reasons not to see there's
some wooden acting here and there but I
mean it's not enough to actually like
you'll pretty much forget about that
this is the second yeah anything else
starts burning our reasons to see you
know that like those things are
necessary for a movie like this I'm not
gonna say it's a great movie so yeah
it's a good really good action movie
yeah it's for what it is it does what it
does really well and it does set itself
apart from generic action Ferrell so if
you're gonna be nitpicky about it then
yeah you're gonna find a lot of reasons
not to see this
subscribe please yeah click right here
to subscribe subscribe and then click
Ryan's bicep if you want to see more
videos I'm really proud of that bicep oh
yeah it's got a tricep to